good morning welcome to friday morning
at ndc
uh my name is james lewis i'm just going
to sort out my glasses
so i can see things
so i'm going to start with a little
story
about my favorite author who's a british
fantasy author called terry pratchett
so terry pratchett he was quite a humble
guy
and when he went to conventions even
though he's probably you know after jk
rowling he's probably the biggest
selling
british fantasy author
when he used to go to conventions he
used to wear a t-shirt and it said uh
said tolkien's dead
jk rowling said no
philip pullman couldn't make it
hi i'm terry pratchett
that was his t-shirt so a little while
ago because he's my favorite author i
thought i'd have my own t-shirt made
along the same lines as terry pratchett
which i'm wearing today right so
this says
cheering's dead
martin fowler says no
sam newman couldn't make it
hi i'm james lewis i'm the other
microservices guy
now this came in handy
this came in handy a little while ago
because i got sent an email
and the email said this
said hi james how are you from jacob
i thought this is exciting it's jacob
from ndc i haven't heard from him in
ages right and it's been you know two
years we've not been doing much
face-to-face we're doing the live
streaming and i thought
brilliant
this is the next line sam newman can't
make it
[Laughter]
to ndc oslo so we're looking for a
replacement
any chance you can do the workshop
to which i immediately unobviously
replied
[Laughter]
so i think i'm the first choice for this
but it could be sam newman and if it's
sam then
sorry you got me instead
so a little bit about me um so i work
for a company called thoughtworks i've
been there a long time now coming up to
17 years um which means i've seen lots
and lots of different clients we're a
consultancy we build uh software for
people
these days i spend most of my time
waving my arms and
wrangling ctos and
doing yoga with them and whatever ctos
do
um but way back when you know i spent a
lot of time building things like
distributed systems for banks insurers
retailers and a little while ago myself
and my colleague martin fowler i had a
sleepover at martin's house and we wrote
a paper defining the microservices
architectural style we said we cannot
say there is a formal definition
of the microservices
architectural style
and then we went on to identify a set of
characteristics
that we were seeing sort of emerging
around microservices projects around
about 20 11
so this is the sort of the netflix's of
the world this is the guardian uh
newspapers of the world these are some
of the investment banks building um
trading platforms and so on
and we were trying to identify the set
of characteristics that we
we felt made these uh these these
software architectures successful
um and these were the characteristics
right so
componentization by services business
capabilities decentralized data blah
blah blah you've probably all seen these
before
in the intervening time my interest has
sort of changed slightly i still write
software i still write code you'd be
pleased to know if there's no although
there's no code in this
i still write code but my interest is
sort of deepened into
trying to understand whether there's any
underlying set of characteristics even
underlying this set
and not only underlying this set but
underlying how we think about designing
organizations as well as software
architectures and enterprise
architectures
is there a set of common things a sort
of you know root
that all these can be sort of traced
down to
if you look at some of these
componentization by services business
capabilities products not projects
decentralized governance all of these
things in some way talk to the idea of
decoupling cohesion
small units of things whether that's
small teams building smaller services
organized around you know smaller
product lines
uh or whether that's you know
decentralizing
um our governance and pushing governance
down to uh the people who know the most
rather than relying on the people who
know maybe the least taking decisions
there seems to be something running
through some theme underlying theme
running through this
and so i'm going to take you through my
journey over the last few years
around how i see the underlying
underlying characteristics of
microservices team topologies and
software architecture
along the way i'll be talking a bit
about elephants and blue whales hope
that's okay also a thing called the
etruscan shrew which is the smallest
mammal
in existence it's about the size of my
thumbnail
i'll be talking about how cities work
and i'll be talking about why amazon
specifically aws
is winning so it's a bit of a journey i
hope you stick with me you've got
nowhere else to go frankly so unlucky
so first up team topologies and
complexity
so when we talk about team topologies
obviously this is synonymous with the i
think canonical text now
team topologies by emanuel pace and matt
skelton
who spent quite a long time in you know
they're part of their route of
or spent a long time as sort of members
of the london devops community or the
london sort of ci and cd community
and they took a lot of stuff that we've
been thinking about as an industry uh in
terms of the micro services
characteristics how to do org design
conway's law and put it into the great
book they wrote team topologies which i
love because it gives us a common
vocabulary around how to think about
teams
so i was at an event a little while ago
it was in
it's a terrible life i have i was in a a
workshop in the caribbean on the
caribbean island of anguilla
and there were a number of people there
one of whom was melvin conway now he
actually exists he's a real person right
i thought he was a myth mel conway but
it turns out he's a older gentleman but
still active and still interested in
software he came to this workshop
and in this workshop one afternoon we
had an open space
where we were talking about the uses
that we'd put conway's law to
and there was someone there from netflix
and the person from netflix was saying
you know well actually we design our
entire building around conway's law
right so we have our you know ux teams
sitting at one end of the building then
we have our platform api teams and then
we have our micro service teams then we
have the infrastructure teams the idea
being if you don't need to speak to
someone on a day-to-day basis they sit
further away and if you need to speak to
someone quite often they sit close to
you so you can have that sort of
serendipitous communications
obviously this is in the before times
slightly different in the after times
so you're at this event and we were
talking about this mel conway was you
know he wrote this paper back in the
late 60s right he couldn't believe that
these giant sort of you know billion
dollar unicorns are organizing
themselves according to the principles
of the law he sort of wrote down around
organizational design mirroring software
architecture the mirroring hypothesis
in 68 69
there was something else that came out
of this meeting someone else who was
working for aws who was there and they
said this the bigger we get
the easier it becomes to get bigger i
can't tell you who it was chatham house
rules and all that but they sort of said
they made this statement
and as aws gets bigger it's easier to
get bigger as we add more people
it's easier to add more people as we
have more products it's easier to add
more products in fact they said the only
limit is our hiring the only limit to
how big we can get and how fast we can
go and how many products we can release
is the number of people we can bring in
and on board
i mean is that
usual
for big companies
because they're a pretty large
organization there right aws um how many
of you in the room work for a large
company i mean i'm over a thousand
people
so a few of you quite a few of you
how many of you would say as you add
more people it gets easier to add more
people
there's one person sitting at the front
oh standing at the front
one person one person
this sort of flies in the face really of
common wisdom around how we scale teams
and scale organizations scale our
software this you know this the received
wisdom is the mythical man month right
you know it's it's the idea that as you
add more people the slower we get
because the communication overhead
increases
so i was intrigued by this and i started
looking into why this might be what are
aws doing
and other organizations as we'll see
that enables them to do this that as
they scale they get this
this effect where they get faster and
bigger more quickly
so i'm going to talk a little bit first
about value and flow
so
my belief is that the goal of a
successful organizational design is to
optimize the flow of value right what
else is subordinate to that
what do i mean by that it's the opti to
optimize the idea of products the ideas
from product people the ideas from our
business
and to be able to easily and quickly
flow those ideas through into some kind
of product production state and i think
that's true for anything whether that's
digital products whether that's physical
products whether that's you know an
orange being transported from a field
onto a supermarket shelf and into your
house or if it's just a website a
feature being built and delivered on a
website
i quite like this
quote from daniel tergus north
the goal of teams and optimizing teams
and self-reflection in teams should be
to safely and sustainably reduce your
leads time to thank you
i i like the thank you bit it's not
enough to just get it into production
someone has to be happy it's there right
and say thank you at the end
so this is the idea of flow the flow of
value from idea into making money saving
lives whatever it is
but that does beg the question what do
we mean by value incidentally
i've got conference coffee i was really
looking forward to terrible conference
coffee it's actually quite good here
which is rather disappointing actually
cheers
what is value what do i mean by value
value can be anything really it's stuff
it could be physical goods it could be
products being shipped through you know
onto a supermarket shelf into your home
or it could be digital products
essentially they're kind of the same
thing
like you know an item of clothing that
zara is selling
versus you know the feature i'm
deploying on my you know on my on my
government website or whatever it is
they're kind of the same thing in some
sense because all they are is stuff raw
materials
in the case of what the majority of us
do day to day it's um digital raw
materials if you like it's bits
we're going from you know an idea that
someone has and we're adding more and
more information to that idea as it
progresses through a value stream until
finally we deploy that idea in some
concrete form into production
whereas for example for zara uh you know
that that's going to be an item of
clothing but they're the same thing you
know zara there's a designer or any any
uh closed retailer that is a designer
who's going to do a design they're going
to you know put their pen down that
design gets then sent to a manufacturing
facility the manufacturer makes it and
it progresses through a series of you
know warehouses via lorries until it's
at a stop and you shop and you buy it
if you squint everything all these
systems pretty much are the same raw
materials and being optimized the flow
of value into production or some form of
production incidentally
zara amazing organization i don't know
if you've read anything about them but
from um i mean they're not far north of
here in acarunia aren't they the the
head office i was there for a little
while
they can go the designer puts the pen
down
15 days later that design is being sold
around the world
that's a pretty cool supply chain isn't
it 15 days from penn down to
in in the store
so what is value value i think is
anything right anything that gets
progressively uh you know uh
moves through this sort of value stream
into some production-like state
but the question is how long it takes
and as i said with zara they optimize
their supply chain such that they go
from pen to store in a really really
short period of time often the
organizations we work in big or
certainly in big organizations they've
accrued lots and lots of sort of scar
tissue over the over the years
so that value stream that value chain of
getting from idea into production can
take a while this is a real value stream
map
up here how long this is how long uh
it takes to
go from idea to production for single
liner code in a retailer in the uk
that's not a short process right this is
not a short process incidentally
this laser yeah laser works that blue
square there
that's writing code that is
all the rest of it
is all the other stuff that's accrued
around how they get stuff done apologies
if this looks like a bit like your own
value streams but you've got you know
assists your system integration testing
uat performance testing regression
testing
uh service handover et cetera et cetera
et cetera and up this end um you've got
you know
requirements uh
development into bit into documents and
options and selections and this is my
favorite bit here where
these are two sets of data architects
they've each got their own canonical
model
don't think they know what canonical
means
and they just update each other's and go
around in a circle
four weeks
brilliant
adding value there right
so how long does stuff take often it
takes quite a long time
many organizations have value streams
that look like this so why is it that i
think team topologies are so interesting
well team topology is the book team
topologies
it identifies a set of team structures
that help us to optimize for the flow of
value talk explicitly about four
different types of team
we talk about streamlined teams
so
understanding what your value stream
looks like and organizing teams around
those around those products
the products not projects long-lived
streamlined teams we then have enabling
teams um enabling teams of you know
those sort of scarce resources that we
can't get enough of there's never enough
security engineers there's never enough
user researchers
right how do we use those most
effectively we use them as consultants
in enabling teams we have complicated
subsystem teams there's this really
gnarly kind of you know risk management
thing down here we might need a team to
work just on that because they're going
to build up the knowledge to do so over
time and then platform teams
who you know provide tooling and a
platform to enable the other teams to go
faster
so bear in mind this is this is the team
topologies setup
so what about software architecture and
complexity
because i've had three things in the
title software architecture team
topologies and complexity science
i'll come back to this quote the bigger
we get
the easier
it becomes to get bigger
as i said you know fred brooks this is
the received wisdom adding manpower to a
late software project makes it later
because at a certain point the the
information flow the increased overhead
of communication between people means
you slow down means you get slower
this was true many years ago and it's
still true in the majority of cases
there i mean who identifies with this
statement still
yeah majority of the rooms putting their
hand up here
um and this is why i was thinking this
is so interesting so i went away when i
heard this statement from the person at
aws and i put some numbers together so
pseudograph any data scientist in the
room yes there's not many data points on
this it's all that were publicly
available and what this is
this shows amazon aws is growth in terms
of people it's actually amazon's growth
in terms of people and growth in terms
of revenue this is plotted log log
what we can see
the 0.49 doesn't really
mean anything but the 1.15 exponent
on that line from that graph
it means that amazon indeed are growing
faster than they should
as they add more people as they double
in size they more than double the
revenue they're generating
as they're adding more people they're
more than generating the revenue that
they should
this is not usual
you know as we double in size normally
what happens is we slow down a bit and
we don't generate exactly double the
revenue we generate slightly less than
that well i'll come on to that and why
in a moment
so again why is this
why are amazon doing this
how are they doing this and i thought
back to you know the famous memory from
jeff bezos 2004 i think it was
where he issued a set of directives if
you like a set of constraints on how
amazon was going to operate moving
forward
some of these include teams must
communicate via interfaces
right we we're not going to communicate
via databases anymore we're not going to
fertile with each other's privates
to you know murder the old c plus plus
joke
um but we're going to communicate
instead by apis clearly defined apis
that are externalizable
all interfaces i must be able to sell i
must be designing the interface to my
team
as if i was going to sell it to someone
else
and then finally the famous one two
pizza or we'll come on to it dunbar's
number teams limiting team size
so these are architectural team
organizations and all organizational
design constraints that were imposed on
the amazon organization way back when
way back in early 2000s
is there something about these
constraints that's meant they're now
growing faster than they should
faster than most of the rest of uh
organizations on any of the exchanges
i think what they did here what jeff
bezos did is he implemented or he
encouraged amazon to implement a set of
forcing functions for flow a set of
forcing functions to maximize the flow
of value from uh from idea through into
production whilst limiting the blast
radius while limiting uh the size of the
architectures uh the systems that his
teams were building
so limited interactions to nearby teams
go back to that netflix example sit next
to people who you need to speak to a lot
team isolation
in the same way that we want to decouple
our software from other software and
have cohesive software we want to do the
same thing with teams it's conway's law
again
now the mirroring hypothesis when we
talk about teams we also talk about
architecture
and we scale by this idea of dunbar's
number which is a social construct which
i'll come on to in a second
so talk a little bit about team
topologies talk a little bit about
software architecture
but what do i mean when i talk about
complexity
so this is something i sort of went down
the rabbit hole on some some number of
years ago
this topic of complex adaptive
systems
so complex adaptive systems they came
out if you like from this institute
called the santa fe institute which is
in new mexico it's no no no coincidence
it's in new mexico because santa fe is
quite close to los alamos
famously where the manhattan project was
wrong
now still the
national laboratory in the us one of the
national labs in the u.s
and a lot of the folk working in los
alamos on things like chaos theory and
before that on things like monte carlo
simulations von neumann he he he
invented monte carlo
at los alamos to model plasma physics in
exploding imploding calls actually
a lot of those folk got interested in
this idea of chaos theory complexity
and they set up this institute called
the santa fe institute for the study of
complex adaptive systems
so what do we mean by complex adaptive
systems
pretty much complex adaptive systems are
anything everywhere you look
you see a complex adaptive system every
biological unit you look at is a complex
adaptive system the organizations we
work in are complex adaptive systems the
world in which we live the cities in
which we live
and mice and elephants are complex
adaptive systems
so this
this graph shows
uh the body mass per kilo
uh it's basically the metabolic rate of
mammals as they get bigger
and the interesting thing about this
graph is you see the straight line when
you actually look at the exponent of
this graph
what you find is the exponent of
that line is the x to the is 0.75
what what this means is that metabolic
rates in mammals they follow this thing
called a scaling law with an exponent of
three over four
it's a bit weird but as you double the
size of of a mammal
you only need 75 percent of the calories
that you think the mammal should need so
as you go from you know a dog to a small
pony i should work out what's twice as
big as a dog really as you go from one
thing to a slightly bigger thing or
double the size of a thing it doesn't
need to eat twice as much food
you think it would it needs to eat or it
needs to take in you know 75 percent of
the calories in which it should
there's another scaling law out there in
terms of companies organizations
if you look at uh you know sort of
doubling the size of organizations over
time
as you double the size of organizations
the revenue that they're taking
you see a similar pattern a similar
scaling law
this is from nasdaq
nasdaq 100 and what you find here is
again the slope is three over four the
vast majority
of organizations of companies as you
double in size you get 75 of the revenue
out
it's a similar scaling rule
revenue scales with the number of
employees following a scaling law of
about yeah 0.85 as you double in size oh
got the 75 wrong sorry 0.85 85 percent
of the revenue out
similarly if you look at another complex
set of complex adaptive systems which
are
like cities you know conorbations if you
look at if you look at the cities of
utrecht and rotterdam for example which
are roughly double in size
what you find is as you double the size
of a thing you go from a village to a
small town to a bigger town to a city to
a mega city etc
the spending on infrastructure only goes
up by 85 percent as you double in size
you only need to get 85
of the
uh water pipes the sewage pipes the
electricity pylons the number of petrol
stations
it's not double the number of petrol
stations as you double in size it's 85
infrastructure scales with population
with an exponent of 0.85
so at this point you're all thinking
great well i started off talking about
software architecture and teams and
organizational design what an earth is
he talking about now well what i'm
talking about is coming back to the set
of underlying characteristics
because whenever you see straight lines
across lots of different areas you
should be asking yourself the question
what is the same about these things
are there any relations between them
that's really at the heart of science
jeffrey west puts it very well he says
quantities that do not change when other
parameters of the system change they
play a special role in science
it's a great book it's at the end of as
a reference but scale the universal laws
of life and death in organizations
cities and companies
and what we're talking about here is
this concept of economies of scale right
this is what our cfos love right this is
when we need economies of scale you know
want to be as we get bigger we're going
to get economies of scale we'll sip
certain people together economies of
scale et cetera et cetera
and what economies of scale really means
technically from an economics
perspective is if you have on a log log
graph linear scaling this straight line
as you double one number you double the
other
economies of scale means you get this
concept of sub-linear scaling
as you double one number you get less
out on the other axis less than you'd
expect and the cities mammals metabolic
rates
and uh and uh
and organizations they all exhibit
as they scale this idea of sublinear
scaling sub-exponential growth
so what's that got to do with complex
adaptive systems why am i telling you
all this
well that
this idea around
around sublinear scaling can be
explained by a set of very simple
characteristics mathematically this is
there's mathematical proofs around this
this idea of self-similarity
the idea of self-organization
complexity
and emergence
so what do we mean by self-similar so
self-similar is for example cells in the
in the body of a horse and a human they
are self-similar to one another
self-organization um you know
apart from the dna you you go from this
you know incredibly simple
single cell to this complex mammal and
it's a self-organized
growth pattern basically you get
complexity which you mean by which we
mean the whole is greater than the sum
of the parts
if you run the same thing twice you
don't get the same results twice and the
idea of emergent behavior
now how does this relate to things like
teams and software
if you think about when we're writing
software when we're on teams
every single every single time we write
a piece of software
right
we're building a complex adaptive system
within a complex adaptive system
if you take one component out one person
is ill for a day if you take
one person and swap them for another
person we're going to get a different
outcome at the end of it it's a classic
example of a complex adaptive
system
and these causes these complex adaptive
systems they can be explained
mathematically by these three simple
principles
the first one is the idea of space
filling fractal networks so in this case
i've got a hierarchical space filling
fractal network so an example of this in
mammals is our circulatory system that
is a space-filling fractal network an
example of this in an organization is
the communication pathways through the
hierarchy of the organization or if you
like through the value streams of how
the work is flowing
the next thing is this idea of invariant
terminating units
i'm trying to get our staffing folk in
thoughtworks to stop calling us
resources
and start calling us self-terminating
sorry invariant terminating units
instead i think that's a much much
friendlier term you know i mean it's
better than meat bags which was also on
the table at one point
besides you've invariant terminating
units in companies that's people doing
work in in organisms it's the cells uh
and in in cities it's things like the
houses that people live in
and then this idea of optimization
complex adaptive systems are able to
self-optimize based on feedback
so in the case of cities the feedback is
is sort of based on economics as it is
in companies in in mammals it's based on
evolutionary feedback over time um
selective processes
so complex adaptive systems they're
everywhere they're yeah we're in one now
we live in them we live in we work in
them and we are complex adaptive systems
and they can be described by these three
principles
um
the key thing is that these three
principles explain this these scaling
laws that we showed hierarchical fractal
networks they scale following a power
law with an exponent of uh of less than
one as you double
anytime you have a hierarchical fractal
network as you double the size of a
thing city organization mammal
you need less than you think of in terms
of calories less than you think in terms
of infrastructure and so on and that's
dependent on the hierarchy
and incidentally they're self-similar
across scales so walmart on a
convenience store they're the same
they're just different sizes
i'm going to talk a little bit now about
corporate metabolism
so why does revenue growth slow as size
increases
i showed this graph a little earlier so
as you double the size you don't get
double the revenue
why do metabolic rates slow as size
increases so as you double the size of a
mammal you don't need double the amount
of calories the reason is the metabolic
rate of the mammal slows down
and it's down to this idea of something
called back pressure
so in any hierarchical fractal network
what you end up is this idea of
self-optimization
where you have bigger things turning
into smaller things if you look at our
circulatory system we have a heart then
we have the aorta they alter splits into
two arteries splits into more arteries
and more arteries and more arteries
every time those things split
evolution has optimized us so that the
artery the the cross-sectional area of
the arteries
add up to the same cross-sectional area
of the arteries they split from
and the reason is kind of obvious when
you think about it the reason is if you
didn't do that you'd get essentially
turbulent flow where the arteries split
so when our blood is pumped out from the
from the from the heart goes into an
artery and it gets pumped through all
the arteries to our cells and back again
if you didn't have this idea of equal
cross-sectional areas
as the blood hit a split in the arterial
system there'd be back pressure putting
pressure back up on the heart causing
the heart to beat to do more work which
we've optimized out of because it
basically gives us heart attacks this is
why plaque buildup is a bad thing
because it narrows the arteries and it
stops them acting as so efficiently
in terms of cross-sectional areas and
back pressure
essentially when we go from one thing to
a smaller thing
in complex adaptive systems in
hierarchical fractal networks what we
get is the one thing splitting into two
equally sized things that add up to the
one thing and this is true in cities as
well so we'll get a big water pipe
coming into the city which splits into
smaller water pipes into smaller water
pipes the smaller water pipes till it
hits our homes the homes are the
invariant terminating units this is true
in companies as well in terms of the
infrastructure that they have
and this is all implied by hierarchies
so hierarchical fractal networks
basically explain the metabolic rate
changes in in mammals
if you look at a mouse and you look at a
whale essentially at the bottom the
cells are the same size right these are
these invariant terminating units the
only difference between these two these
two animals is the depth of the
circulatory system
the depth of the hierarchy if you like
and that depth of hierarchy the number
of levels in the hierarchy
that gives you this metabolic rate
decrease
here's a fun fact elephants and blue
whales they don't get cancer
why don't they get cancer
well because they operate so slowly
their metabolic rates are so slow that
the cells don't have enough time to
develop mutations to get cancer
that's how slow the metabolic rate is of
uh of an elephant and a whale
they operate really really slowly so if
you're an elephant looking at humans
running around you're seeing people just
go
in the same way that when we look at a
mouse the mouse seems to be running
around really really fast because their
metabolic rates are so much faster than
ours are
consequently they also live for
different lengths of time mice live for
a short period of time whales elephants
live for a really really long length of
time based on metabolic rates
so bigger animals it turns out are more
efficient because they've got this deep
hierarchy of circulatory system and
their metabolic rates are much much
slower and so they turn out to be more
efficient you don't they don't need as
many calories as smaller animals
this is down to this idea of impedance
matching in the circulatory system the
hierarchical network split and branch
and branch and branch and branch until
you reach some cells this is driven by
feedback from evolution
this is also true for companies
when your cfo says economies of scale we
want to be more efficient bigger
companies are more efficient because
they've got these deep hierarchies of
infrastructure infrastructure costs
scales at 85 percent as you get bigger
but they also develop deeper hierarchies
as they age they develop deeper
hierarchies of infrastructure and deeper
hierarchies of information flow
and they optimize based on feedback from
market forces
but the key thing is both mammals
and organizations slow down as they get
older
so i'll come on to a bit about flow now
i've showed that value stream map
earlier
um if you sort of take one of these
ideas of a hierarchical network
hierarchical fractal networks you can
think of a value stream as one slice
through the hierarchy the information
hierarchy of an organization
and so when you've got these really long
value streams like we see here like i
showed earlier what that's showing you
is that there is a really deep hierarchy
through which information has to flow
there's a really deep hierarchical
network
and the other thing you do when you do
things like plot value streams is you
start to find things like queues
you start to find where the information
flows start to split and where back
pressure is building up so cues in our
organizations cues of work cues of ideas
that's essentially the same as plaque in
mammal's arteries whenever we have a cue
it's putting back pressure up on the
informational sort of hierarchy of an
organization slowing stuff down it's
making the organization work harder
slowing things down
don ronson in the principles of product
development flow anyone who was in my
talk yesterday would have heard me
talking about this
uh he talks a lot about cues he talks
about you know the impact of cues uh on
on on on the work that we do
and he talks about this idea of
impedance mismatching the idea that as
information is flowing it's been blocked
it's been stopped
it's building up in these sort of
backlogs essentially and you know think
of software developers we all know cues
and messaging systems if a queue is
backing up that's not not a great thing
right it's putting back pressure up the
system and you know it's it's a it's a
uh it's it shows that the downstream
systems aren't able to keep up with
things that are happening
so to recap on corporate metabolism as
companies scale they add more and more
processes and hierarchy as we get older
we add deeper and deeper hierarchies in
terms of information flow our value
streams extend and extend and extend oh
we had this problem in production one
time we'd better put in a six week uat
period or six week regression period
suddenly you've got an extra six weeks
before anything can happen you have more
processes
as you add more people oh how do we
manage these people we will add more
people into managed deeper and deeper
and deeper hierarchies every time we add
hierarchy the math shows
that things will slow down
our metabolism the corporate metabolism
the team metabolism slows with hierarchy
that's just inescapable it's physics
it's math
there is maths to prove that
things slow down with hierarchy
but we also as i said deliberately block
our corporate arteries by adding in
these cues by having like lots of stuff
building up waiting to get done it's
putting back pressure up on the uh up on
the corporate heart if you like
it's a bit of a sidebar can we identify
when this is happening another great
berkeley seminal book really
is accelerate
by nicole fosgrim first author jess
humble and jean king which summarizes
the state of devops reports over the
years
and in that they identify four now five
key metrics that we can use to identify
whether our organization is performing
well or not whether our teams are
performing
um we've probably come across that
here's a fun fact as a result of this
research who's who in the room has got
to change request board that they have
to talk to or an architectural review
board
one two is anyone listening
excellent people are still listening
that's good there's a few hands going up
the research from dora that summarizes
accelerates
it shows that change change
change request boards predict low
performance and i use that term
precisely
if you have a change request board or an
architecture review board
it's a predictor of you being a
low-performing organization in terms of
i.t
it's not correlated with it predicts it
and why is that
it's because every time we put something
in like a change request board we're
again blocking the flow of information
it's basically like you know we're
deliberately stopping the heart beating
every now and again before letting it
start again
so can we do this can we use these
metrics to monitor organizational health
well these metrics mean time to recovery
cycle time
change failure rate number of deploys
and now i think they call it uh
scalability i'm going to say i can't
remember what the final one is
by monitoring these we can actually
understand how fast we are going what
our metabolic rate is as a team as an
organization
we can identify how old we are if you
like and if we're getting older or if
we're getting younger
so i think we can by using these they're
the equivalent really the leading
indicators of organizational health
they're the equivalent of going to your
general practitioner your doctor and
them taking your blood pressure and your
pulse you know your temperature
it's not going to tell you exactly what
the problem is but it's going to give
you a pretty good idea of whether you're
sick or not
and as i say they're leading indicators
and that's super useful
it's like monitoring heart rate and
blood pressure
and so we should work to improve these
down north daniel tearhurst north you
know he has this lovely phrase as i said
quoted at the start working to safely
and sustainably reduce lead time to
value
that's what he means we're working
safely and sustainability to improve
these metrics to get stuff out into
production and people saying thank you
more effectively working on flow
efficiency but
it's a big but
it doesn't matter how good you are at
these you're still going to be limited
by the hierarchy in which which the
organization has
you can only improve to the point that's
imposed by the hierarchy the
hierarchical fractal network that makes
up the complex adaptive system which is
the organization
next up organizational mortality
so it turns out companies die right all
the time
the half-life of a company on a listed
company
any one particular company you know on
average the half-life is 10 years 10 and
a half years there's 50 churn
every 10 and a half years right
companies get taken over they go out of
business they become insolvent they get
bankrupt etc why is that
well it seems that as companies age
not only do they get slower but they
also do some other things
they tend to spend less money
they make less investment in terms of
research and development the thing that
made them successful at the beginning
is no longer as important the product
development the innovation
that's subordinated to the hierarchy to
cost efficiencies to savings you know to
being to be
like managing risk and governance and
these things
they lose track of what made them
successful to start with what made them
young if you like the investment in the
products the flow of getting those
products in front of their customers and
making them happy making them say thank
you hopefully having them say thank you
so as they get as they get older they
spend less more money less money on r d
and you end up with more hierarchy off
usually more processes
more constraints
and when you put these two things
together what you end up with is this
idea of like like humans as we get older
we have to have more constraints we get
plaque buildup eventually we die
so too true for companies
so with companies hierarchies they tend
to grow and grow
and at the end of it they die
so
hierarchic hierarchies hierarchical
organizations or any form of
complex adaptive system with a hierarchy
in it will gain economies of scale for
infrastructure right about 0.85 as you
double the size of a company
you only have to spend about 85 percent
on infrastructure but they also achieve
sublinear growth in revenue same about
the same numbers
and over time the metabolic rate of the
company reduces and eventually
in general organizations will die
sorry that's the sad bit i'll go on to
the good news
next
so scaling complex adaptive systems
there's another type of scaling rule
associated with growth we talked about
sublinear scaling which is where you
double the size of one number and you
don't get double out of the other one
there's something called super linear
scaling scaling in advance of the
exponential as x doubles y increases by
more than double
and if you go back to what i was saying
about amazon at the start
that's kind of what that exponent was
1.15
and cities
exhibit both types of scaling
cities achieve
super linear growth for socioeconomic
effects innovation wages professionals
crime disease
pollution as you double the size of a
town or a city you get more than double
the amount of increases in these things
all the socio-economic factors they
scale super linearly
while you know infrastructure scales
sublinearly
turns out if you ever realize if you
ever noticed if you walk if you're
walking around a big city everyone seems
to be walking faster
it's actually true
there's been research done based on
mobile phone data by mit
uh and as as you double the size of of
of of of a town people walk faster with
an exponent of 1.10 they walk 10 faster
as you double the size than they should
up to how fast your legs will go yeah
which is uh it's just pretty cool isn't
it
so what is it about cities what are
these socio-economic what's what's the
underlying
reason that social these socio-economic
factors scale superlative it's about
small world fractal networks a different
type
of fractal network talks about
hierarchical networks small world
networks like social networks like the
networks you have with your friends and
family like basically every zoom call
that you had with your mates right right
these are small world networks
where you have highly connected nodes
and slightly more loosely connected
nodes
then we'll recognize these numbers
so these i mentioned at the start these
are dunbar's numbers so we all often
think of dunbar it's a set of research
into the number of connections if you
like that people hold
and the closeness of those connections
to them we often think about this done
by a number of about 150
that's the
more most commonly sort of understood
dunbar number and actually thoughtworks
we'd scale our offices by the dunbar
number of 150. any more than about 150
people and you don't really know them
personally anymore you know you can't
say you know oh hey jacob how's the kids
and all that kind of stuff you know how
was the golf trip this weekend they
become sort of faceless so if you scale
by dunbar's number about 150
you tend to know everyone in in in the
same office as you but dumbbells number
there's a range of them it goes from
five all the way to 500.5 is like your
nuclear family which is a bit awkward
because i've i've got four kids there's
six of us
either i love one of my kids less or my
wife
which is
a bit tricky
but about five
up to up to about you know 500. and
these are your nuclear family then your
extended family then your close friends
and acquaintances then the sort of you
know the set of people you might be able
to rely on then the set of people you've
probably got in your phone book or
something
and these
these networks social economic uh small
world fractal networks they drive this
idea of returns to scale
so on the one hand we've got hierarchies
and they drive sub-linear scaling on the
other hand we've got small world
networks which drive
super linear scaling
how is it that this works
with hierarchies you've got no real
option but to increase the depth of them
right they go information flows in one
way
but with small world networks you see
they see this in cities you can add
little bits on the outside a little bit
more on the outside a little bit more on
the outside
so they sort of grow by adding little
pieces
i know there was a talk on fractal
architecture i think earlier in the week
i've got this idea that you should be
able to actually
measure the fractal dimension of an
architecture because fractal dimension
of a city indicates whether it's healthy
or not
you can actually measure the crinkliness
of the outline of a city and it will
tell you whether the city
is healthy or it's not
and it's because you add these new more
crinkly bits around the outside the
higher the fractal the higher the
fractal dimension uh the healthier the
city
similarly i suspect with
architectures although i've not measured
it myself
you add these little bits on the outside
you don't need to increase this depth of
hierarchy you don't need to increase the
length of time it takes
you know for information to pass between
things
so as cities grow
they gain economies of scale for
infrastructure
the game returns to scale for
socioeconomic factors
they rarely die most cities don't die
you know there's the odd one even
detroit which is a famous you know
famous city that was in decline is now
rebounding we know this because the
fractal dimension is going up
and in fact they get 115 more stuff both
good and bad
higher wages but more disease
more professionals
but more crime
but for 85 percent of the cost
sounds like a good thing really you get
you get returns to scale and economies
of scale
so are there any organizations out there
that have taken advantage of this well i
think to an extent the company i work
for thoughtworks are as we've scaled
we've created small small fractal
networks by opening more than one office
for example per country we don't have
one big office in the uk we have one in
manchester we have one in newcastle we
have one in london
similarly in india we don't have one
giant office in benilou we have a number
of offices even in bengaluru and then we
have lots of other offices all the way
around we try and scale by keeping these
sort of fractal these small world
networks so that people know each other
we take advantage of these networks
you could argue that spotify is a
spotify model is a classic example of
how to scale using small world networks
how to scale teams around small bits of
software squads and organize them in as
loosely a coupled way as possible with
as little hierarchy as possible just
enough
to make sure communication happens
and then famously valve they
leaked it was leaked their employee
handbook a little while ago several
years ago now actually and in that
employee handbook they have this picture
to describe how they organize
those
basically they they put it out there we
are a small world fractal network this
is how we want to organize zero
hierarchy it's based on socio based on
personal relationships
people get to work on what they want to
work on and things that valve
and finally back to amazon where i
started
coming back to this graph with
amazon's growth this exponent of 1.15
they are clearly scaling super linearly
so why is it they are scaling super
linearly in terms of revenue
as i said at the start there's a set of
forcing functions that were put in place
to enable a set of small teams to
operate independently from one another
often to the detriment of users of
amazon software aws is software anyone
who's used any of the aws apis knows
that you can jump from one to another
and there's often no similarity at all
right it's because the teams are
completely independent
but what that means is they can add more
like cities ads suburbs on the side
amazon just adds another little team
building another little product and
another little team building another
little product
doesn't impact the rest of the
organization and as they do that they
get this virtual circle where the
products that they build can be built on
with other products can be built on by
other products
so as most companies get bigger
it gets harder to get bigger
as most companies get bigger they tend
the metabolic rate decreases things go
more slowly and eventually the company
will die
but as amazon gets bigger it's getting
easier for them to get bigger
and it's based on maths
if you look back look at the book where
i started team topologies the
streamlined teams independent with the
other team structures that are you know
that are combined
to making those streamlined teams go
faster those are examples of patterns
for implementing small world networks in
your own organizations
you know these streamlined teams
enabling teams etc etc fundamentally
that's what team topologies is about
it's about creating the socio-economic
structure based around small world
networks not hierarchies
so in summary software architecture team
topologies complexity science i started
off talking about the characteristics of
microservices you know the idea of
decoupling of decentralization pushing
stuff out you know decision-making down
to the people who know the most um you
know building decoupled software
cohesive software and organizing around
business concerns business capabilities
that's what we identified are the
starters these characteristics
you know i think if you take the team
topologies
uh set of teams the the the archetypes
in team topologies they correlate very
nicely with what we were talking about
in terms of microservices and not only
that they also when you look at the
complex adaptive system theory
underpinning it all they kind of are
almost a guidebook for implementing
small world networks
so social networks imply
super exponential growth
hierarchy slow metabolic rate inversion
of control for teams forcing functions
for flow these are the things we want to
be thinking about to go faster
i'm going to finish there these are all
the books that i referenced during this
talk
sorry if you work in a hierarchy
i'm james thanks very much for your time
this morning
[Applause]